hmm yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Piquet is that PK 15 yeah I
think it's PK 15 sometimes it looks like
an L anyway this is a new opponent never
played him and I've got a cat alone now
maybe Jeff will play some bogor style
here with a regular Catalan I'm not so
comfortable to be perfectly honest the
only line that I know reasonably well
it's very it's very boring and here I
feel like I'm yeah knowledgeable and now
if let's say it should be seven think
it's Bishop e7 I know they go Queen d4 i
believe ya hear black can go for Bishop
f3 and 96 but I think castle is also
fine twenty four nights is 6 i'm playing
for my good or playing with good
development creature for I am a
particular threat then root belongs here
anyway so let's do that interesting
prevents 95 ok I can do d5 here just for
just play on the development I wonder ok
I go for that it's a different difficult
decision they also was like 97 for
example symbols like that opening up the
diagonal and plain ig6 maybe next yeah
that was my it was a move that I
expected
my compensation hopefully compensation
for the bishop is the good development
but it's the bishop path okay if i take
c for now queen takes i have discoveries
yeah i think i'll probably should do
that at home threatening to be five okay
so this was clear i think 95 now is pin
sorry is leading to trades yeah it
should be okay Queen will move I don't
think he can we cannot sex the crania in
any meaningful way I don't think so so
yeah this is happening and now Knight
takes it sounded so simplifying even
what oh that's very that's very I was
thinking with the pawn to leave a little
bit more live in the position okay well
Bishop t6 don't think this is a big deal
so I double him
you
yeah it's probably still rather equal
yeah I don't know maybe 97 get rid of
that bishop I can go back actually maybe
you can go back yeah but ok it's no good
square Bishop see three Pepsi three
maybe no oh that move I overlooked ah
what a blunder here oh my goodness I
simply didn't see that
any tricks nauru th th Roope t1
I could buy weight with a 25 maybe maybe
Quincy five letters F form I anyway
that's the only thing that might work f
for Queen g4 takes the 722 would be
immensely lucky if I'm not directly
losing now it's got Queen d8 made just
got queen d 8 with me to come
hm
okay wow that was a big blunder plans
Jim there wasn't really cooing there
wasn't much going on you was a pretty
equal ish position my 97 is just is just
blundering the whole game now thats the
engine move my opponent played that it's
just very equal this position he's doing
that yeah there's this not really much
to check i think it was a pretty clean
game up to my double ? move just nothing
going on he plays those moves yeah it's
just equalizing it's not not much to say
the big development is good enough for
black to equalize this position I think
don't think white can can do much here I
want to briefly check the alternative
here 98 it's a bit passive or now he's
playing all those moves I don't really
like that now he's playing something in
okay only way is to start this new hmm I
mean I don't want to look at it in much
detail but I just want to check if I'm
equal down if you have something
probably something like age six maybe
also he's really not doing much him
roped you one
I'd rather be wider with the bishop but
it's not there is nothing apparent what
he what you can do here something like
this that's not very doesn't look very
positive for black let's save it I can
like in sometimes do things like that
young rookie and here if we pay trade
one pair of rooks yeah just very equal
ish and I made a big blunder there okay
thanks for watching